ooh good timing can you play an
instructive Italian or ponziani
but again against the French I can't
play either opening
I'll play a two nights attack how about
so after D5 I'll play Knight C3
and it's an opening that probably more
commonly play against Carol Khan
but
it's an easy opening to pick up for
whites
maybe there's no guarantee black we'll
play D5
OKC also wants ponziani
I'll try and deliver at some point this
tournament
but we'll we'll need to get E4 E5
exchange French it's already too late
for
if I wanted to play exchange French I
could have taken and played D4
in terms of Chess Bliss great content
thank you Mr patu
who I formerly called Mr Potato
also welcome back Johnny biscuits
so we're going into one of the main
lines
and the idea of this line is not
actually to like keep the Pawns in the
center very often black will play C5 and
even sometimes F6
and in these cases I'm more than ready
just to take the Pawns
and this variation it's more about piece
play
especially with the knights and Bishops
uh the main line is C5 takes and then
I'll get this set up with Bishop D3 and
Bishop F4
and the pieces will find hopefully find
some Harmony
this is a line I learned many many years
ago
used to be one of the like main things I
played against the French online
these days I mixed up more
I uh play some Ortho snap
play some Wing gambits
the other day I had a really nice game
um the last title Tuesday
I beat Grand Master rustamov in this
French Advanced variation
I ended up sacking three pawns and then
later on I sacked some pieces
but here we have uh kind of the the
quintessential development for white
and there's a few moves for Bach there's
castling there's F6 there's Queen B6
so castling
is it's a move it's following opening
principles but it pretty much loses on
the spot
and that's one of the really nice things
about this variation is the potential
for the Greek gift
and now we're gonna see black
regretting their life decisions
but still question because I have Queen
D3 or H4
um or queen G4 Queen G4 allows 95
I'm looking at each four and they takes
E5 H5 King F6
so I'm pretty sure I've studied this
exact position at some point
and I'm gonna go with um
was basically my first impression is to
put the queen on G3
and this does not look fun for black to
defend
but looks really fun for white to attack
now I could take on E6 which is kind of
a triple Fork
but I don't think there's any need
let me calculate so Queen G3
Queen E7
maybe what I do there is play H4
I was looking at Queen G3 Queen E7 96
King F7
but I want the king to just run away
so okay let's start with Queen G3
yeah the big problem is the king can't
run backwards
Knight is really well placed there's
guaranteed discoveries
I'm threatening to win I mean this would
be like a quadruple Discovery Fork type
of thing
and King H6 doesn't help because it
walks into the diagonal of the bishop
it is true I could have taken ampa slot
with check
because the pawn would be removed but
after it takes King takes there would be
Knight H7 but I think white would run
out of steam a little bit
in that line
here I'm just gaining Steam
really not easy for black to find a move
so Queen E7 probably the best try
and my
yeah my game plan is to play H4 I think
I'll go ahead and just do it
I mean it can be fun to calculate all
the discoveries but
um yeah there's a pretty lethal threat
of H5 here
but does H5 lead to force mate
H5 King H6
I take King H7
at some point I'd probably take the Rook
take the pawn
life will be good
yeah welcome back to more people
because the bishop got stuck with
deciding how to allocate my time in
games how do you know when to keep
evaluating a position and when to just
make the move you have in mind
yeah that's a fair question
every situation is different
and a big part of getting better at
kind of time management is through
experience
it also depends how much time you have
like in the classical game if you're
playing an over the board game where you
have 90 minutes or two hours per side
you can easily spend like five to ten
minutes in the more critical situations
but if you're playing like online Blitz
or rapid
then then you have to judge in what
situations to rely more on intuition
I mean generally
I mean it's kind of a skill within
itself is to identify critical moments
and then kind of have in the back of
your mind
whether or not you're gonna spend time
in
in the critical moments
um
so and like in this position for example
I could have spent a lot of time like
calculating but I figured I'd go for a a
move that just kind of keeps all the
pressure
and now here
shoot this is interesting so blocks
giving back a piece
now do I want to throw in
if I throw in this discovery
doesn't really do much
and if I take
yeah this isn't super straightforward
I could play I could play H5
like here I'm I'm slowing down because
there are options like I could take and
play H5 and both of them have their own
lines to calculate there's also this
movement of three
um that allows the king to run back
let's look at H5 because I'd imagine
well if King F6
I fork
King goes back I take
and whatever takes back I win the Knight
albeit material there
so the king have to go here
it goes there I
probably Knight of seven at the very
least I also have 96
okay let's calculate 96 King H7 is
forced
wow there's almost ampa sanchak means
okay I'm going for each five because it
seems good in every line there's a funny
line King H6 Knight takes E6 G5
but it's not mate because Queen H4 but
then it's checkmates
uh such a funny on Passat it's on
passant double check too
we're probably not gonna see it play out
uh would be really funny though I
remember like seeing a um someone that
run a script to generate like a bunch of
games that ended in Opus on checkmate
and I reviewed some of the best ones and
this was like an a very common theme
among those games you take on
um like after G5 you take on pump a song
on G6
but uh yeah we're not seeing it play out
here
now yeah the calculation was 987.
I also have I have this move too
oh there's so much fun
to be had
I'm slowing down again because
yeah I gotta look at my options
there's also Queen H4
just guaranteed discovery
but I think I just cash in like 97 came
here and then I take
and then whatever it takes I take the
knights and I'll be up material
yeah sometimes these
um these Greek gift style attacks
it's common for them to end in Checkmate
but it's also common for them to end
with
just white getting some material
advantage
yeah I'm essentially up the exchange now
I have a rook for Bishop
and both nights are hanging
if black saves this Knight I'll save
this Vines if black takes and I take
so life is good why not Queen G6
oh yeah Queen G6 would lose a queen
sometimes easy to miss a backward Night
Moves
I think black's doing their best job to
at least stay alive for a bit longer
because I'm not immediately like mating
or anything
but the position's still really nice
isn't this position not sound
yeah it's less sound for black
all right so the queen defends a bishop
it's a question now if I wanna
go in with the Knight to retreat with a
knight I think I just retreat
and I can
find a new home on the king side
after the game I'll share some um
some of the funny lines maybe some
additional ideas from this opening as
well
used to be one of my favorite openings
to play against the French
these days it's just it's fun to mix
things up
I'll play King F1
I could play C3 but more interested in
just winning the pawn
the king is pretty safe here I think the
Rook is happy to stay on each file
Eric do you have secret prep to show us
so I leak more preparation
at this stage of my chess career
I'm really fine like sharing whatever
secret prep that I have
that's one of the benefits of
I guess still playing competitively but
not really trying
like since I'm not really really trying
to get the Grand Master title I'm sure
just sharing whatever like cool things I
find
um I'd like to play another four I'd
like to play this
I would like to play this
is Rook H4 a lot of moves to choose from
now this situation I should not
overthink because
like whatever I do like as long as I
don't blunder
should be doing well
so I'm deciding to improve one piece
that was not doing anything
and with Rook C8
cannot happening immediately
I'll keep the queen in the center
Rook H3
oh the bishop is on D6 though
maybe now it's time for another four
so I'm allowing this but then Queen C4
check
and if that gets to G6 then
yeah I think it's got even better
there's also ideas of just going after
the epon like rookie one
C4
hey it's me Brady what's up neat Brady
shout out to Nate
I think Nate was also streaming this uh
rapid tournament
hope you had a good one
I played Nate uh a few weeks ago in the
same hourly rapid Arena
and they're
is very likely to be a YouTube video
coming
uh Knight G6
yeah if you're just joining this is my
first game of the tournament
I did
late join the tournament
but have a nice position
trying to finish things off
oh wow
wow
am I in trouble
that's a double attack
uh I have to take I think
wait it's not so simple
yeah
I've kidney too as well like King E2
might just save me
because then
actually King E2 looks quite nice
delayed bong cloud
it's not what I really wanted but
I think it's what I have to do
so this way Bishop G2 or queen G2 no
longer come with check this bishop is
still hanging my Rooks defended
I think things are okay
I should have been more alert to Danger
though
yeah Rook D it's definitely the best try
I'm thinking about taking
and queen E7 check
there's also Queen H4
and queen H4 it's not so simple though
the queen H4 Queen G2
maybe Rook G1
yeah kudos to my opponent for fighting
back like using the bishop hair
my Rooks are
I mean purely defensive here
at this point I just want to trade
Queens
that's a tricky move I think Rook H3
just defend
is there a sound
not hearing sound
foreign
thanks for all the great content
E5 wow
okay maybe now this
oh thank you Crowley 54 welcome back
yeah the Knight defends the queen
so now I'm up a full Rook
a full two Rooks
I lose this but no my queen oh yes my
two Rooks
welcome back to lioro Lucky
so this is checkmates this is checkmate
okay
I was fortunate to survive there
um yeah I let things slip a little bit
like maybe F1 wasn't the safest place
for the king
Rook C1 may have been just not a useful
move
like maybe I should have started with
this or this I do want to show the funny
line though
because if if King H6 it's so close to
ampa sanchak means
I would
I would play this
and the idea was of King H7 I take the
Rook with check
like here it takes takes takes and
other F4 I just take yeah this would be
nice
so I was looking at G5 and then on
passant double check because both pawns
remove themselves so now the bishop and
King
or bishop and Rook are jacking the king
and it's one of these rare double checks
that the two pieces checking
did not move on the previous move it was
a pawn that moves
and it's not quite mates but it's mate
after
oh it is neat
it is meat
oh that's so funny I was calculating
Queen H4 but the bishop is also checking
so you can't um yeah you can't block a
double check I was wondering why I
couldn't grab the queen
oh that would have been a funny
alternate finish to the game
yeah this line is is pretty venomous
actually
like this position has been reached
over a hundred thousand games on the
chess
and 16 000 people have castled which is
just a blunder
and it's crazy because the most common
move
is Queen B6
which looks good at first because it's
attacking this Pawn in this Pond but
um if black plays this move then they're
on the verge of falling into another
trap white can simply castle and if
Queen digs B2 which is the most played
move
there's another trap here
uh Knight B5
I'll leave the database open
and there's been almost 20 000 games
and now the queen is very stuck White's
threatening to Fork on C7 there's also I
believe there's a threat of Bishop D2
Bishop C3 for having the queen
and then if castling
white can
it's actually really important to play
correctly here is white because I I
think Bishop D2 is working
but even stronger is Bishop takes H7 the
same Greek gift
but after it takes Knight G5
King G8
this is white to move
and I've turned off the database because
I'm I want to keep some suspense
but I want to run a poll here white to
move
how would you continue
and there's two moves to choose from
there's Queen H5 and queen D3
I've shown this on stream maybe a long
time ago
but it's it's been a while
I'm thinking I'll put this whole like
game and Analysis on YouTube
so if you're watching on YouTube feel
free to comment below the move that you
would play
we can see in twitch chat
uh
I want to hide the board but
we see the poll here
69 for Queen H5
31 percent
okay it's shifting a little bit
a little bit more time to vote
some people are right some people are
wrong
okay 68 percent
for Queen H5 32 for Queen D3
so it would be a very very bad mistake
to play Queen H5
even though 77 people want to play this
move
and let me see the stats
yeah Queen H5 is the most played Queen
H5 is a typical Greek gift to move
but it walks into Queen takes C2
defending from a distance
and white just has no attack here
like sacked the bishop and there's not
really a follow-up and black is just of
a piece in winning
so it's very very important
to start with Queen D3 which is not a
typical Greek gift move but it has the
same threats
and um yeah black usually plays G6
there's not too many moves here
uh G6 or F5 we're going to do the same
thing but then we swing over to H3
and the difference here is because black
moved the g-pawn the diagonals
obstructed Queen C2 no longer covers H7
and White's just I think mating by force
right hey it's Josh what's up Josh
just in time for
some crushing attack
yeah if you're just joining I just play
the game from a fun opening against the
French
and I believe this is forced mates yeah
I just made a few more moves same thing
with F5
F5 Queen H3 and there's no Queen C2
so
it's a good one to know
but if you play this line as white you
should
you should be aware of the Greek gift
after castling and then this line or if
they take on these two instructions
oh thank you chasak
so anyway this is going to be a whole
YouTube video
how to crush the French defense with a
two nights attack
hope you enjoy the video subscribe if
you want to see more content like this
subscribe to ax or typo if you want to
see Scrabble content shout out to
axotypo